what is popping Valhalla heads it is me
Mt and welcome back to the heavy spoiler
show The Adventures of Richard Daniel
Sanchez and morer chony Smith continue
with episode 9 of an insane season 7 of
Rick and Morty an episode where spoiler
alert Richard and Mortimer meet their
untimely demises at the big hands of a
big fooot almost ending the Richard and
Mortimer program as we know it if it
wasn't for the power of religion and
science mostly science science I for one
am dying to talk about this episode with
all of you wonderful homies so let's
just dive into this thing shall we the
title of this newest episode is called
Mort Ragnar which is of course a
reference to Marvel Studios Thor
Ragnarok and the Valhalla Centric nature
of this episode and the episode opens
with Jerry Smith setting a record for
TV's most annoying family member as he
annoys his dead grandparents in the
afterlife after dying eight times this
happens after Jerry is somehow convinced
by Rick to become a guinea pig and die
repeatedly in order for Rick to gain
valuable scientific data about the
nature of the afterlife when Jerry runs
into his grandmother in the sky I notice
that his grandmother looks a lot like
Jerry and Jerry's father Leonard Smith
leading me to assume that this
grandmother was from his father's side
Granny Smith then informs Jerry that his
constant lack of commitment to death has
annoyed his grandfather enough to no
longer show up to see him but before
Jerry can explain to his grandmother
that his father-in-law is a mad genius
he is brought back to life in a hospital
bed by w and Morty a hospital bed design
similar to the one found in the 2017
remake of flatliners a movie about a
group of young people who purposely
briefly end their own lives in order to
gain insight and intelligence from the
other side the original flatliners
actually came out in 1990 and stars
kefir southernland Julia Roberts and
Kevin Bacon whereas the 2017 remake
Stars a female presenting elot pagee
kiry Clemens Diego Luna and Nina do brev
but what's interesting about the 2017
movie in particular
is that it is revealed that Elliot Pig's
character who initially came up with the
idea to induce death in the name of
science only did so in order to see a
dead family member in the afterlife
again which could potentially be what is
subconsciously and secretly motivating
Rick with the creation of this machine
with his hunt for Infinite Energy just
being a sweet extra bonus with Rick
Prime being successfully wiped off his
plane of existence Rick needs to find a
whole new reason for living and while
Yes Rick has been slowly getting his
mojo back in the episode since he
covered himself in the blood of his
mortal enemy he still feels a massive
Dian sized hole in his life and likely
wanted to confirm if she still existed
out there somewhere in some capacity
after Rick Prime wiped her out of
existence on a multiversal scale at any
rate this episode is a clear homage to
those flatliners movies but as the title
of the episode suggests this episode of
course seems to also be taking a lot of
cues from the Marvel Cinematic Universe
in particular the mcu's interpretation
of the afterlife existing as a separate
plane of existence where the Mind
energies of dead humans aggregate
together into groups according to their
individual beliefs with that mind energy
being represented as yellow in the MCU
much like it does in this episode it's
why Warrior Believers of the Norse
pantheon like Jane Foster went to the
Norse afterlife of Valhalla why rocket
was transported to an afterlife of open
cages in an Open Sky in Guardians 3 and
basically the MCU science behind the
eternals and how they're able to
repeatedly die and come back to life
because the eternals believe in the
celestials as their religion their
yellow mind energies are sent to the
world Forge as their afterlife being
stored as yellow mind energy in these
weird Cubbies made by the celestials to
later be reinserted into new bodies by
the celestials but anyways as Rick
Tinkers with his computer after making
this discovery of a gold mine of raw
Consciousness energy the Tree of Life
symbol can be seen in the top right
corner of his computer screen according
to the tenants of sacred geometry the
tree of life is a symbol associated with
the connection between this Earthly plan
and the Heavenly one as well as the
afterlife in general then after the
intro Rick and Morty head to the frosty
Hills of Norway where Rick finds his
clone and initiates a phoenix protocol
which involves downloading his
Consciousness back into a clone of his
body after he figures out a way back
from the Afterlife with the Phoenix of
Phoenix protocol of course referring to
how the fictional flamed phoenix bird
explodes in fire only to be reborn again
Rick sure does love him some cloning man
like he literally is always doing it but
what I found particularly interesting is
how right after this Morty informs Rick
how his being desensitized to seeing
Rick die over and over again has raised
a major red flag with his counselors at
school a school that went as far as to
call Homeland Security after taking a
look into Morty psyche and I honestly
think that this is the show's purposeful
way of showing us how our Morty
definitely has a little bit of evil
Morty inside of him and that after
enough adventures with Rick there is
still a potential for our Morty to snap
and become as sensitized to killing as
evil Morty does however it is due to the
growth of character that we've seen
manifest within Rick himself throughout
this season thanks in large part to
Rick's therapist Dr Wong this universe's
version of Rick seems to be a lot Kinder
and loving to his family and while he
may get grumpy at times he also has
grown to apologize more and call himself
out on his own BS so our Morty becoming
fed up with Rick and becoming evil seems
unlikely besides two evil mores would
just be boring and then they would have
to share the eye patch which is you know
how do you even coordinate that but
anyways in order to send himself to
Valhalla Rick needs to die in glorious
battle against a mighty enemy so my man
just whips out a Pokeball from Pokemon
out of his [__] because if you had an
interdimensional portal gun you would
probably have a Pokeball too so I
respect it our editor Matt noticed that
Rick's Pokeball looked a lot like the
park ball that you used in Gen 4 Pokemon
games in Pal Park and you know what
Matthew I'm going to have to agree but I
also think that Rick's Pokéball also
sort of looks like the friend and Nest
pokeballs as well but the part ball is
right on the money but unlike in the
Pokémon Universe instead of a red light
Rick's Pokeball shoots out a lime green
light when summoning his pocket monster
with the big ass toes but anyways when
Rick enters his personal death chamber
we can see that he's covered his walls
with bloody Nordic runes for the ritual
then he of course summons Bigfoot and is
immediately turned into a puddle of
blood something that was actually teased
all the way back in episode three of
this season in Air Force Wong the
president introduces Rick to an alien
called flea an alien that the President
says might be able to tell the future
fle Flack then draws a picture of
Bigfoot murdering Rick while warning
Rick of danger a threat that Rick
ignores in the episode however given
what we learned about Rick going out of
his way to capture Bigfoot just to
torture him there is a chance that Rick
might have done this in an attempt to
escape this flea Flack prophecy on his
own terms with science because if fate
dictates that Rick might have to die by
big foot's big hands and feet then Rick
is fully within his right to prepare the
exact conditions for that prophecy to
happen just feels like something Rick
would do but anyways after Rick dies he
arrives at Valhalla and is quickly sent
off to go get his armor so that he can
live die and repeat with his new
Valhalla buddies just like Tom Cruz and
Emily Blunt do in Edge of Tomorrow this
entire episode has major Edge of
Tomorrow Vibes with all the fighting and
dying and resurrecting though there is a
noticeable lack of Groundhog Day time
travel when Rick arrives at the
blacksmith we can see a hammer modeled
after Thor's hammer from North mythology
and the visual style of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe movies then after
Morty accidentally dies after letting
Bigfoot loose the people of Valhalla
confront Rick the witch who quickly
refers to himself as Odin in order to
fool the V Hollands to leave him alone
he also calls himself Spider-Man's Uncle
seemingly mixing up Odin and Uncle Ben's
characters in the Marvel Comics which is
odd and hilarious Rick also references
the TV show Undercover Boss when
pretending to be Odin as well back in
Norway parts of Rick's cybernetic body
actually go flying as Bigfoot uses
Rick's corpse to try to get at Rick's
clone prompting Rick's AI to activate
the cybernetic implants within the Clone
in order to animate the Clone just
enough to evade Bigfoot clone Rick then
climbs a Norwegian flag pole before
Bigfoot is then apprehended by Norway's
police and brought to the Vatican by the
Pope's secret agents Bigfoot is then
introduced to the pope who appears
Loosely modeled after the current Pope
Francis when the pope reveals to Bigfoot
that he has clone Rick and chains we can
see that the Vatican placed a golden fig
leaf on Rick's penis much like many
Roman sculptors used to do when covering
up the genitals of their art the use of
the Fig Leaf in particular is due to the
story of Adam and Eve in the Bible when
the two decided to cover themselves in
fig leaves when they experienced the
shame of nakedness for the first time
but anyways Morty then wipes out wave
after wave of Nordic Warriors using a
minigun mines and some automated drones
and editor Matt actually spotted that
Morty actually uses a Valhalla version
of the gall horn from Destiny 2 which is
fun considering that the gallah horn
also has ties to the Norse and Nordic
religion as Heimdall himself was
prophesized to use a horned Galler horn
instrument to Mark the start of Ragnarok
I also love the added detail of all the
people who die in Valla coming back to
life in a glow of yellow light much like
Jane Foster does when she arrives in
Valhalla and Thor for but anyways Rick
finally manages to find a way back home
but before he does he creates two winged
battle suits for him and Morty in the
style of vultures wing suit from
Spider-Man homecoming and flies around
in that suit with his personal meal
while calling Morty Spider-Man and later
after Bigfoot carries out a series of
ridiculous assassinations for a petty
and hateful Pope the pope Awards Bigfoot
with a wrist translating device that the
Pope says that he bought from a predator
from the Predator movies for the price
of three muskets this is of course the
second time we get a predator reference
this season as Mr Poopy but hole's
ex-wife is dating the Predator who
fights Rick and his friends earlier on
in the season but after Bigfoot finally
gets to attack the real Rick Rick
upgrades that translator to give him a
deep voice voice akin to famous movie
trailer voiceover artist Don Le Fontaine
rest in peace what a king when testing
out his new voice Bigfoot starts
pretending to narrate a trailer for
2011's In Time starring Justin
Timberlake and Amanda cyh but anyways
Rick Morty and Bigfoot then work
together to confront the pope channeling
the power of belief to become an all
powerful being much like how the
Universal Church of Truth does with
their faith generators in Guardians of
the Galaxy number one from 2008 one of
my favorite Comics but during one of the
many times the gang get an ated by the
Pope the pope shoots out a beam of
energy with his two Palms connecting
like he was some type of Goku from
Dragon Ball Z right before Rick whips
out his shield but disintegrates anyway
which felt a lot like exactly what
happened to doctor strange one of the
many times that he faced doamu while
repeatedly resurrecting himself with the
time Stone then when Bigfoot gets a new
manlier body Rick tells Bigfoot to dial
his caveman talk back so he doesn't
sound like a muppet which is a clear
reference to animal the Muppet from the
Muppets we then get a reference to the
TV shows r Warriors and Mobile Suit
Gundam when Rick whips out his red super
suit that he used in season 4 episode
7's poly morus with Morty wearing an
orange version of The Purge murder suit
from Season 2 Episode 99's look who's
purging now but when that doesn't work
they somehow decide to graduate to duct
taping pillows onto their bodies which
definitely sounds like a Morty or Jerry
idea if I'm honest then we get a
reference to the 1987 film Monster Squad
when Rick assembles a vampire a swamp
fish monster a werewolf a mummy and a
Frankenstein to fight the pope but after
that fails Rick decides to just cut the
pope off from his power source and catch
that Italian monster within his pokeball
with the show even making the Pokemon
shaking animation that happens when you
try to catch a Pokemon in the game and
finally the post credit scene features
the return of the Pokey Pope to do a
pokey battle in an arena modeled after
the Pikachu Charizard battle arena from
the detective Pikachu movie with their
opponent looking like a hybrid between
Ash Ketchum from the Pokemon anime and
the red red Pokémon trainer from the
Pokémon games but anyways that is it for
this breakdown of episode 9 of season 7
of Rick and Morty what did you guys
think of this episode let us know in the
comment section down below and of course
I want to thank our editor Matt for
helping me out with a number of Easter
eggs in this episode Matt is one of the
biggest frecking Morty fans on the world
so it's always great to have him helping
out in these videos but anyways you can
follow me at mastertainment on Twitter
Instagram YouTube or wherever I am on
the internet and hey you can even catch
me on the Guardians of the paly podcast
on YouTube just search for Guardians of
the paly but most importantly do not
forget to subscribe to heavy spoilers
here on YouTube because my boy Paul has
the best breakdowns in the business my
guys and you do not want to miss out but
again thank you guys so much for
watching you guys are amazing and I love
that you guys spend time with me it
really means a lot to me love you guys
so much and I'll see you guys later
goodbye